in this morning's money watch how you
can save money when gas and food are
getting more expensive we've got new
inflation numbers that just came out
they show prices in february were 7.9
percent higher than the same time last
year that's more than the 40-year record
high the u.s saw in january prices are
also rising at the pump everyone knows
that by now a new record every day the
average price of a gallon of regular gas
hit
4.32 cents overnight
aaa says it's up 59 cents in the past
week alone drivers in california are
paying an average of
5.69 cents a gallon cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger is with us good
morning jill good morning and you have
been speed reading through this new
inflation report 7.9 what does that tell
us uh it tells us prices are on the move
this actually of course is mostly the
period before russia
invaded ukraine so we don't even account
for that but just to put a fine point on
it as you said these are the highest
price increases annually since january
1982
and the food price is also very high i
mean we always focus on gas which is up
38 from a year ago terrible food costs
up 7.9 food at home up 8.6 the bureau of
labor statistics says that's the highest
since 1981
and when you go down and you drill down
through all these numbers it sort of
feels like everything's going up and
it's only going to get worse and the
white house keeps telling us prices are
going to come down they're going to come
down but that was before the war in
ukraine yeah and when the price of gas
goes up the price of everything goes up
absolutely shipping and transportation
as well i think that we are looking at a
period now where we can pretty clearly
see that eight and maybe even nine
percent inflation is on the horizon and
that things again this is predicated on
what happens in ukraine but we don't
look till the end of the year looking
like we get back to more normal
inflationary lessons so the economy is
strong jill uh and we know last year
hourly wages
rose 4.7 percent overall wages were down
but if wages aren't growing to keep up
pace with inflation right americans are
going to feel it even more absolutely
and you know what we see is that there's
been a lot of analysis that even though
prices were up last year because of all
the stimulus and relief efforts the
child care tax credit a lot of
households did okay this year is going
to be different and that means it is
incumbent upon us as individuals to
actually go and try to get for get a
raise try to get a bonus we have new
reports that show us that if you're a
job changer if you change jobs you're
going to get a better raise than if you
just stick around i know that's hard for
a lot of folks but you've got to at
least look maybe get a bonus maybe work
from home a couple days a week if
possible because that will at least ease
up on your gas and your commuting costs
okay so that might be an easy way to
save a little money at the pump what
about the grocery store if wheat prices
are going up that means that trip to the
grocery store is going to be costly any
advice there yeah absolutely you know i
was doing some research for this i found
out that the whole idea of generic and
private label branding came about in the
1970s
spike of inflation so if you can go to
generics it is a huge help and we're
talking generics are now about 20 of the
total of of sales in the grocery store
obviously buying in bulk and checking in
sales you may want to actually carb up a
little bit and skip the proteins i just
see in this report that meats poultry
fish and eggs are 13
so a lot of people are trying to do
meatless mondays to help us listen as a
son of two parents who worked nine to
fives plus overtime and raised four boys
generic branding was the way to go for a
long time and we were trying to make
ends absolutely thank you so much jill
we appreciate you